his anger and his rage was so crazy
sometimes Natalie and I were living at
his house Denise didn't want the kids at
the house understandably shaman I was
fine with that right well he was going
crazy I didn't like that he threatened
her to me constantly I am the one he
confided this these crazy weird thoughts
to and just the things he would say
about Denise and his plans for her when
he would say things like don't worry I I
know how to make people disappear or
make it look like it was an accident
could have been trying to look like a
tough guy to you too you know and hey
don't you [ __ ] with me because I'll get
you you know I mean guys go through all
kinds of bravado so I mean look he
shared dark thoughts with you I know the
difference between like Oh manda big
business me overcome but it was like he
would like have like really methodical
fantasies yes
and talked with me about it and I'm like
do I say anything to Denise is this just
the steroids talking like what it's all
confusion it it is very compute and
looking back like I said so it's the
dumbest thing I ever did dating him